proverò a iniziare raccontandovi la mia
vertigine visto che la nostra ideatrice
ha Infatti questo invito io a dire il
vero meno vi ringrazio per l'invito e
meno male che solo quest'anno abbiate
avuto l'autorizzazione perché se la
veste avuto qualche anno fa non avrei
potuto rispondere di sì al caropino
perché cingare fa io per amor della
verità lo devo dire ero in galera nel
senso proprio sta dietro perché
partecipare a un progetto culturale che
si chiamava caffè ristretto mi fecero
girare nelle carceri pugliesi so che non
mi inviterete più nelle carceri pugliesi
per parlare ai detenuti di poesia a
Lucera a Foggia a Bari a Turi pensate a
Turi Turi è un carcere a sentenze
definitive stavano prima che cominciassi
a parlare C'è il 50% Come state seduti
voi in due gruppi io scambiavo devo
parlare di Leopardi scambiamo due parole
direttrice quando improvvisamente uno
baldazosamente al primo banchetto
maestro quantiattura sta cosa qua io
immaginavo dici perché ci tenevo devi
uscire stasera non so cioè un
appuntamento dove devi andare che devi
fare Oh quello un po'
sconcertato Non vi dico ciò che disse
del giudice perché disse qdc.com mi ha
dato tre anni e 7 mesi Allora dici Io
stai Buon Siediti può durare pure ehm
tre anni e 7 mesi io comincerei a
parlare dell'infinito è quello si alzò
di nuovo e gridò comunque maestro Io qui
sto per sbaglio si capisce tutto sempre
sbagli tu Anch'io mi trovo per sbaglio e
ti spiego perché io
cinghia che avevo 58 anni primo giorno
di prima elementare 51 anni fa mio padre
mi venne a prendere all'uscita di scuola
poi non ci viene più non venne più per
tutta la mia carriera scolastica ma
nemmeno il giorno della laurea Credetemi
il contenuto più altro che visto che
sicuramente ci sono molti insegnanti qua
certi rapporti scolastici che non sono
potuti chiusi che avevano l'ascolto dice
Eccoli gli insegnanti maestri Come va
mio figlio come va Come diceva ieri io
ce vieni a fare e che dice posso tornare
tu Pino per educazione del signor può
tornare quello a due giorni dopo Tien di
notte maestra oggi signori ciù c'era
ieri ciucciu Cioè fino a fà c'è fino a
fa' Invece mio padre no coerente bontà
sua mi piacciò sulla bicicletta mi fece
questa domanda il primo giorno di prima
elementare disse Trifone A proposito dei
nomi trifoni io non so strani trifoni
chiami
Trifone ti piace andare a scuola
domande difficili il primo giorno al
bambino io Sbagliai la risposta Perché
dici sì sì mi piace papà sono 58 anni
prima ho detto che non si riesce ad
uscire da questa benedetta scuola molto
più intelligente di me e mio fratello di
un anno più piccolo anche con lui mio
padre era mio padre andò l'ho preso il
primo giorno lo piazzò sulla bici Nicola
Ti piace la scuola no un uomo felice da
moglie
però cosa aggiunti a quei detenuti quel
giorno e dico a voi Tanto non ci dà tre
anni David moi chiudete cosa dissi
Leopardi cosa dice quella siepe quel
muro una malattia la carcerazione mi
impedisce di andare oltre ma la poesia
cosa dice io nel pensier mi fingo Io
sono più forte della carcerazione della
pandemia malati Io sono più forte il
poeta non è la poesia Il poeta non
scappano dalla realtà la poesia non è
fuga dalla realtà una poesia e
potenziamento della realtà la poesia È
questo è come il QR Code Se volessimo
usare un linguaggio moderno
buono gli fai clic e ascolti la canzone
o vedi un filmato questo è la poesia È
questa è stata la mia vertigine per cui
faccio l'udito didattica questo stile
vale in università dove insegno nelle
piazze nelle scuole qui a Policoro anni
fa sulla spiaggia ho parlato del
tremolard della marina in un lido o a
Cerignola in un bar del femminicidio del
canto V del Purgatorio eccetera e allora
gli anniversari A cosa servono gli
anniversari servono a tirare una linea
Questo è il 150° anno della morte di
Manzoni molto tempo prima eh dei dit
francamente è molto tempo e 200 anni
Anche perché nel 1823 uscì la prima
edizione del Fermo e Lucia Allora
tiriamo una linea Vediamo cosa ha ancora
se ha ancora qualcosa da dire da dare
Manzoni con i Promessi Sposi quando io
leggo un libro o vedo un film non io
ciascuno di noi anche stasera voi state
qui state Ascolta Tranne le mie
sciocchezze state ascoltando così Quando
andrete via avrete fatto un passo avanti
leggere un libro vedere un film
significa crescere maturare cambiare
volare io mi posso identificare Ma porca
Don Rodrigo mi devo identificare con un
personaggio devo fare un passo avanti
Devo camminare devo cambiare e maturare
la domanda Allora è questo fantastico
oggi ha ancora da dire e da dare a un
giovane lettore ma anche a me ha un
lettore non più giovane La mia risposta
è no non ha più nulla da dire e da dare
nulla più assolutamente no Io vi invito
state riprendendo qualcuno scattasse
delle foto in francese delle foto Perché
al prossimo evento non ci starò perché
questo è il terzo evento in cui attacco
Manzoni presentando il mio libro
dimenticare Manzoni ma mi hanno
hackerato il profilo mi ha mandato il
messaggio stava spezzò la matti Meno
male Pino nel pacchetto trovate una
malattia che dice t'ammazzarla la
mattina cioè mi hanno hackerato davvero
il profilo Instagram Seguitemi su Tik
Tok gargan Trifone gargan Trip Trifone
non è il cognome che a Palermo non mi
voleva andare la stanza perché avevano
registrato sotto trifoglio il cognome
siamà Dai dai tutta la tutta la vita
perseguitate da stuccarci allora
è molto in Italia è molto più facile Mi
sono reso conto mettere in discussione
la verginità della Madonna ma no la
ciuccia Angela
cioè Dante la Chiama lignavia a Firenze
dicono Gli indifferenti No vabbè non fa
mai chiuso a sé
scrisse Marzo 1821 mentre stava
scrivendo gli bussarono arrestati
lo chiuse 27 anni nel cassetto è tutto
bugie che lui abbia accompagnato il
Risorgimento no se ne stava tremare
dentro casa e finizi E allora posso
uscire quattro volte Don Abbondio chiede
ma è morto Rodriguez sei a mujer ha
visto tu che sei innamorato così fece
lui quando Gli arrivò tre mesi dopo la
notizia di Napoleone ma è Muerte Sì ma
l'hai visto tu che è morto Sì beh Allora
mo posso scrivere cinque immagini non so
se non fa Maione E allora Seguitemi e
poi come può essere un testo moderno
Prima ne parlavo con l'intervistatrice
che tentò fondamentale della Signoria
Cioè in 350 pagine questi due Promessi
Sposi si abbracciano si baciano mai in
da 350 la pagina dei Promessi Sposi non
si baciano mai non si guardano ma di
Lucia la rivedrete Lucia C'ha gli occhi
chiusi sempre che la capra baciato un
po' per il baldacchino che portava un
po' Perché non bisogna guardare in
faccia non si baciano mai non si tengono
mai per mano Pensa che solo una volta in
350 pagine Renzo attraversando l'Adda
dalla mano ad Agnese non alici Questa è
proprio Filia pura e pedofilia allo
stato puro altro che ad Agnese non è
possibile oggi una ragazza quasi tu si
signori lo puoi sopportare un tramonto
che cosa vuoi da me stai Come mamma tua
Sì tre ciccioni non so molto più moderno
Dante Paolo e Francesca
condannati sono b ma son tutto in
verticale e lei cosa dice questi che da
me non Fiat diviso in vischio
ora ve lo dirò anche adesso sempre con
gli occhi chiusi la vedete Ma hanno dato
sembra Goni quelle l'edizione originale
del 1840 poi nel libro spiego come mai
fu un fallimento
1840 sempre con non sappiamo il colore
degli occhi di questa signorina qua mai
E qua si dice l'amore c'è
Non si sa la scena Renzo torna a casa
dopo che don abbozzi più arriva la
katish Luigi Luigi
che non ci sposa più la reazione ah
vabbè come ha fatto la vertigine
350 bomboniere
quello non ci sposa più Ah vabbè come va
bene ninna
inconcepibile una cosa Già vi ho detto
molto più moderno Dante
e altri poi mi invitate un'altra volta
Pino perché c'è un Dante porno che ho
fatto a Rionero in Vulture poi mi
invitate un altro gioco E allora dopo
mesi e mesi di separazione si ritrovano
a Milano nel Lazzaretto la scena è
questa Lorenzo che dice Ah sei tu Sì
sono io punto
lui ha creduto morto lei lei ha creduto
morto lui la guerra
Ah sei tu Sì sono io cioè è un romanzo
proponibile oggi non ha assolutamente no
anaffettiva Lei è [__] lui come dice
mamma cioè non se ne può non se ne fotte
però non se ne fotte non se ne può di
più
anaffettiva Lucia [__] proprio lui
fatto in forma di [__] al vento
perché poi lì Paolo e Francesca
volentieri parleremo
cinque volte la parola vento una volta
la parola
Allora il popolo Urbano è canaglia non
può fare nulla tant'è che quando Renzo
si mette con loro ha problemi invece è
buono il popolo Il Contado quello che
non si ribella quello che accetta la
volontà e così è la vita ma centanze e
non vi dico l'espressione che usavo mia
nonna e remissivo eccetera invece in
città si mette nei guai altro che
educazione civica nella scuola italiana
da alcuni anni è stata reintrodotta
all'insegnamento come insegnamento
trasversale non come singole disciplina
dell'educazione civica dalle elementari
ai licei si tenta di far dire ai nostri
ragazzi ai care come avrebbe detto Don
Milani e questo è anche l'anno di Don
Milani A me interessa Policoro A me
interessa l'Italia A me interessa questo
paese guasto invece Manzoni cosa scrive
L'ultima pagina dei Promessi Sposi Ho
imparato a non andare al Ted Ho imparato
a non parlare in pubblico Ho imparato a
non andare agli scioperi Ho imparato a
non ubriacarmi Ho imparato a non dire
culo Ho imparato a fare le catene
quando dice domestics faccio io la
giustifica indisposizione così se entri
gli amici di Ralph in Gargano
mercoledì c'è uno sciopero un po' di più
lo show fanno Sì condividi quando hai
detto mercoledì c'è una visita medica
mercoledì Questa è la lezione italiana
che parte proprio da Petrarca
Guicciardini e Manzoni nel sugo della
storia Petrarca scrisse nel De Vito
solitaria visse bene chi bene Si nascose
e ci volevi tu credi tutti che vive bene
e chi non dice mai quello che pensa che
vive bene che non si candida mai che
vive bene che non fa Mi sto a casa
Ecco perché Allo scoppio della prima
guerra mondiale
e ci buttiamo o con gli uni o con gli
altri Questo è il qualunquismo italiano
continuo che ha la sua codifica
pedagogica nel sugo di tutta la storia
di quel romanzo chiudo credo ancora non
c'è un minuto Così chiudo su quei
personaggi no Guardate uno il libro non
è il mio libro non era ancora uscito che
mi dice oh faccio schifo pure vuole
Fammi capire
almeno perché dice ti sei fermato alla
critica gramsciana non se hai il piacere
di leggere vedrai che non sto fermo a
Gramsci che accusò appunto di
vigliaccheria di viltà di remissivismo
politico sociale cioè no Niccolò
Tommaseo era un critico cattolico di
quelli più energici sapete cosa scrisse
in una recensione pubblica al romanzo di
Manzoni
scrisse io lo riporto questa frase nel
mio libricino manzò per tratteggiare
Renzo lo hai disegnato come un
coglioncello usò proprio questo vocabolo
l'altro Giuseppe De Luca Don Giuseppe De
Luca Lucano di Sasso di Castalda e
ottenuto degli incontri proprio a Sasso
di Castalda negli anni scorsi poi
Vissuti in Vaticano punta di diamante
del Vaticano consigliere di Giovanni
XXIII amico personale della Allora
Cardinale Montini poi Papa
scrittore di punta dell'osservatore
Romano eccetera quindi fondatore delle
Edizioni di storia e letteratura ancora
oggi la casa editrice nel Vaticano
per fare un esempio corrispettivo delle
Einaudi per il mondo laico Eppure
scrisse un libro infiniti articoli poi
Raccolti in un libro intitolato contro
Manzoni sì e gli scrisse A parte le
accuse di vigliaccheria di Manzoni nella
tua inutile lunga vita mai una volta che
ti sei alzato a difendere il papa di
oggi
agiscono
a voi Sto scrivendo un libro politico
che farà discute se finalmente dico la
verità su un omicidio politico
l'omicidio di Giulio Cesare Giulio
Cesare
devi dire oggi Cosa ne pensi del blocco
sui migranti devi dire oggi cosa pensi
di queste se io ho da elabora devi dire
oggi
che
seviziare Violentare una ragazza ubriaca
Caro Presidente di non so che sono lo
devi dire a tuo figlio lo so che tuo
figlio ma non hai il diritto di
giustificare la violenza su di una
compagna ancorché ubriaca
e io l'ho scritto ogni sabato scrivo su
un quotidiano pugliese l'ho scritto non
aspetto tremila anni non chiedo ma è
morto ma
come si chiama Napoleone così posso
scrivere è morto la Russia così posso
scrivere la porcheria che ha combinato
la porcherie da papà da educatore da
padre e allora scrisse oltre che
accusarlo di ignavia disse potevi non
scrivere sto romanzi e Potevi non dire
che sei cattolico Perché hai messo un
prete Don Abbondio e la pesca cazzotti
ha messo una monaca potevi evitare pure
di scrivere questo questo romanzo
Vabbè chiudo così il mio libro è
dimenticare Manzoni e Ciao a tutti È
stato bello conoscervi non vi non vi
inviterete più io torno in galera Ciao a
tutti